hallo liebe freunde willkommen zurück
bei easyjet wir sind heute wieder bei
klaus im haus hallo claudia lokar sehr
gut danke heute ist der erste advent
das heißt es ist der vierte sonntag vor
weihnachten und mann zelt rückwärts
quasi vier adventssonntage und aus
diesem anlass weil weihnachten vor der
tür steht wollten wir heute mal was
zusammen backen oder klaus ja ich freue
mich schon sehr
du hast dich auch schön weihnachtlich
schon dekoriert genau weihnachten ist
das fest der liebe und deswegen habe ich
ein großes herz mir um den hals binden
lassen
das war so schön dass ich für uns
vorbereitet
dass das klar ist dann fangen wir mal an
das ist deine liebe richtig für
weihnachten
fangen wir mal an mit dem backen los
geht's
[Musik]
was heute wir backen heute plätzchen und
zwar so genannte butterplätzchen oder
auch bekannt als kekse h
leckere kekse wie der name schon sagt
brauchen wir mutter karin
wir brauchen mehr wir brauchen zucker
wir brauchen ein ei wir brauchen
backpulver vanillezucker und eventuell
wer es mag auch ein bisschen vanille
aroma
[Musik]
dem stehen hast du mitgebracht gar nicht
erst einmal weg besser ist sein handy
alberto hat er geschrieben ja schöne
grüße alberto sodann entsperren mal
bitte also klaus hat sich ein rezept im
internet geöffnet und nach diesem rezept
wird klaus jetz den teig zubereiten
wir benötigen 125 g weiche butter
dann benötigen wir 120 gramm zucker 1
päckchen vanillezucker 1 250 gramm mehl
und ein teelöffel backpulver ich bin
nicht mehr mitgekommen das war nochmal
das erste sogar 125 jahren so sieht das
aus wenn profis backen
man hat eine gramm genaue waage wo alles
genau gezeigt wird klaus 125 gramm nicht
[Musik]
lutz kuckuck mal aufs rezept was wir
jetzt noch machen müssen
klaus hat jetzt das backpulver und das
mehl verrühren
damit ich dieses jetzt beim wiener dass
beim umrühren langsam unter den teig
mischen kann da flutscht das schon wie
eine eins supermax ascari ca 12 stunden
im kühlschrank fest werden lassen
somit haben wir gar nicht habe zwei
stunden zeit später was machen wir jetzt
janosch wollte uns ein bisschen was auf
der gitarre vorsprung
wie will mit zwei stunden waren ja zwei
stunden sind um klaus ja hat sich der
teich entwickelt super der sich
entwickelt sieht richtig gut aus
krümelig von der konsistenz her genauso
wie sein sondern ihn so essen
nein ich hab mir früher als kind auch
immer mit meiner mama plätzchen gebacken
das habe ich immer sehr gerne gemacht
ich habe immer sehr gerne den teich roh
gegessen
du auch ich überlege gerade ich glaube
das habe ich auch mal gemacht ist
eigentlich total gewehrs weil man ist ja
quasi ruhe butter mit rohem ei und
zucker sehr gut dabei wenn du sie
gebacken ist ist er auch
also von daher ist unsere dritte groß so
habe ich das noch nie drüber nachgedacht
klaus heizt nun den weg um zuvor damit
wir dort gleich plätzchen backen können
oder unter diese 150 jahren als nächsten
schritt muss klaus den tisch vorbereiten
damit für den teig ausrollen können und
darin die plätzchen ausstechen können
was machen wir dafür kreist wir müssen
erstmal die oberfläche leicht bemühen
aber nur leicht das macht man dafür
damit der teig nicht klebt und abtenau
auf der unter auf dem auf dem ding so
carina jetzt dass du anfangen
das ist doch deine aufgabe das macht ihr
doch am meisten spaß
ein bisschen vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr schon so und jetzt kannst du den
teig schön dünn ausrollen dass wir zum
beispiel so nix jetzt hier schon besser
aus
sehr schön ja genau ich glaube dass das
dumm genug
so jetzt kannst du dich markieren
vergreifen und zwar das sind die
ausstechformen klaus könntest du bitte
vorstellen was ihr hierfür förmchen habt
die form das ist eine blume form einer
förmlichen blumen muss sie sind ein pilz
stern keine ahnung so wir sehen jetzt
hier die verschiedenen formen kannst du
einmal die form zeigen und ich habe mich
jetzt folgendes gefragt das ist ja wieso
wir sind christen all diese dinge
irgendwie was mit weihnachten zu tun der
nikolaus den raum was macht die ente die
du kannst auch mal die frage in die
community rausgeben liebe community
was hat die ente und was hat der pilz
das hat das mit weihnachten zu tun die
kreativsten antworten werden ist beim
nächsten kari antwortete vielleicht mal
vorgelesen aber ich werde er das ist ja
gut ich persönlich freue mich ich will
aber auch gern wissen was ein tannenbaum
mit wein zu tun hat denn jeder weiß es
ist aber keiner weiß warum weißt du
warum jetzt habe ich meinen ersten kicks
mein erster klicks ist fertig also das
macht man jetzt ganz einfach der teiches
ausgerollt man hat die förmchen wie
förmchen drückt man hier ein mann macht
die möglichst eng aneinander damit man
nicht so theike verbraucht und jetzt und
man die 5
die sachen daraus und legt sie auf das
blech mal her
diese kekse kannst du ja auch mit nach
berlin nehmen und kannst sie dann in
berlin läuten schenken und ihnen eine
freude machen
das mache ich zu unserem zu unserer
weihnachtsfeier übrigens ihr seid
eingeladen zu unserer easyjet
weihnachtsfeier
dort werden wir es
aus allen möglichen ländern präsentieren
am 9 dezember geht es los um 7 uhr in
unserem büro florastraße 48 in berlin
also kann man einfach so hinkommen oder
machte daraus unsere zuschauer in berlin
sind eingeladen wir haben ja immer ein
stammtisch in berlin klaus habe ich mit
bekommen ja und dort werden
dort drehen wir deutschland trinken
welchen alles mögliche und jetzt haben
gedacht wir kochen mal zu weihnachten
bringt jeder essen aus einem land mit
finde ich gut
klaus was mich jetzt interessiert ist
ich hätte gerne auch sowas buntes wie
kann ich das machen ja das ist dass es
dann gehen wir dann in den nächsten
arbeitsschritt in diex aus dem ofen
kommen dann werden sie verziert und dazu
gibt es auch sehen die ersten offen kann
ja erst gedacht nachher weiß gar nichts
wir haben hier verschiedene streusel
einmal bunten streuseln einmal
schokostreusel damit die auf den keksen
haften kann man entweder schokolade
erwärmen und eine schokolade darauf
träufeln dann die da drauf dann bleiben
die haften oder auch eine möglichkeit
man macht so ein überzug aus
zitronensaft und puderzucker super dann
machen wir mal neun minuten das ist ja
genau die mitte das ist eine timer time
ist so schön dass jetzt dickflüssig
verrückte zu können damit jetzt auf die
plätzchen drauf gestrichen
viel hilft viel so gut jetzt habe mir
diesen weihnachtsmann janisch muss ein
bisschen näher kommen ein pinsel
damit werden wir jetzt sozusagen den
zuckerguss auftrag auch inzwischen gut
gemacht ja und jetzt haben wir das
aufgetragen und jetzt werden wir halt
die streusel darüber machen teil ist
jetzt mein mond und den würde ich gerne
mit schokostreuseln bestreuen
[Musik]
wunderbar jetzt kommt er nochmal einen
ofen dass der herd hat jetzt einfach so
aus und dann ja das war unsere
episodische heute wir hoffen ihr habt
konntet ein paar back vokabeln mitnehmen
von der episode und wenn ihr lust habt
mal uns zu treffen und was mit uns zu
machen dann kommt entweder am 9 dezember
zu unserer weihnachtsfeier alle daten
gibt es bei facebook auf unserer
facebook-seite oder kommt zu unserer
idee german winter school wusstest du
dass für eine winter school haben wusste
ich echt noch nicht wirklich da kommen
leute nach berlin für eine woche und
will man ein volles programm so richtig
action resse skating schnitzeljagd
glühweintrinken re fan an die ostsee
klaus alles was du dir träumen ganz und
bei allem machen wir immer so lernen
dabei deutschland wie auch in unseren
videos
ich finde das super super wir hatten
schon ist summer school letztes jahr das
risiko richtig dieses dieses jahr eine
summer school das war richtig gut wir
haben tolle sachen gemacht im sommer in
berlin haben die stadt erkundet mit
fahrrad zu hört sich super an und haben
damals auf eine grammatik übungen ja du
kannst ja schon durch
deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich
eingeladen trotzdem kommt vorbei meldet
euch beide links findet ihr hier unten
wenn ihr lust habt uns zu treffen in
berlin und danke dass wir bei dir sein
dürften kannst sehr gerne immer
ja es hat uns sehr gut gefallen hier
genau unterstützt uns bei plätzchen und
abonniert easyjet bis nächste woche so
klaus ich werde jetzt die kekse aufessen